[Music]
hi this is alden ehrenreich
hello everybody i'm harry knight it's
joseph morgan i'm sam mitsuji i'm nina
sonja hannah john carmen here it's
jessica brown finley from brave new
world
close your eyes
[Music]
when the series starts we find john
living in what's called the savage lands
which is this
broken world that they keep to show new
londoners what society used to
look like and it functions as a kind of
theme park where he works as the prop
guy
la nina is already pushing the
boundaries
for monogamy and privacy
but she is sort of quietly going under
the radar
we find helm in her studio bernard is in
a bit of a dilemma
and he's coming to see his best friend
for
advice when the series starts you find
henry in his element
having lots of no strings attached sex
with as many people as possible
at the beginning of the series something
occurs
which is out of the ordinary and she
doesn't like that because
she controls everything so she is
needing to find out
what's gone wrong
you're staring don't stare
the thing about secrets in new london is
that no one has them
and they're kind of illegal and anytime
strange things happen to bernard
which they continue to do he does try to
tell people and they don't want to hear
him
from the get-go c-jack 60 has a big
secret
which is that he has started to feel
emotions
he's started to churn up feelings inside
him that he has no vocabulary to process
in this world there's no such thing as
privacy
you never keep secrets lying is
not even a word and she does quite a lot
of that
the only thing i can say is that she's
kind of a juxtaposition of herself of
creativity control and chaos
a secret that jon has that i can tease
is
that he becomes embroiled in a plot that
ends up having a big effect on
the savage lands that he's not entirely
choosing
people have no idea how good you have it
sometimes i think i want to be unhappy
if i had to describe mustafa in three
emojis
it would be a clown face a devil face
and a skull unhappy face
then the kind of monocle face where the
guy is stroking his chin
but then a thumbs up ah there's the
superhero one the one the mask
um because that's how he sees himself
there's the elvis because he likes to
dance
and um and then there's like the
firecracker explosion
sad face fire
now that's it that's all i've got we're
here to help you transition from your
primitive world of hardship
strife to ours an evolved society of
harmony
and happiness now you're ready to meet
wilhelma watson
see jack 16 henry mustafa john monina
and all the residents
in new london in brave new world now
[Music]
streaming
you